[Music]
in
literal trap house news oh like
you're trapped in there submitted by tom
cruise
oh oh my god i used to be a big fan of
yours
but what happened you were like oh
thanks for watching our channel we
started jumping on the couch that was
odd dude
he was with uh katie homie yep now uh
jamie foxx is with katie homie
what you didn't know that that's a weird
couple they got married or something
right yeah
i don't know about me oh yeah weird-ass
couple dude for a while
you know i didn't realize jamie foxx is
actually really ugly um if you look at
his face
you never realize that he has the same
look as usher but like
because they're so talented they look
good i think he's attractive
jamie foxx take a look at his face again
he's ugly he's ugly when he does that
like wanda character y'all remember
yeah i like wanda like he just has bad
features yeah it's just not a
he's so charming though i think about
him i thought he was the sexiest dude
then one day i just looked at his face i
was like oh yeah you're actually not
that physically
looking for whatever but he's still not
ugly he's pretty up there
you know tyson beckford is a [ __ ]
crazy gun advocate
i just started following him uh and his
like first four posts our second
amendment post and him shooting guns
like a [ __ ] wow
jesus he run he walks the runway but
then don't [ __ ] with him
but ma'am a man was arrested after
arming his home and surrounding property
with dangerous booby traps
dude that is me dude get the [ __ ] out of
my brain
bro why is that illegal why are you so
important that people want to come into
your house no i just want to destroy
people
that's nothing to do with how important
i am oh you just want to [ __ ] with
people
what if they're like trick-or-treaters
and [ __ ] [ __ ] even better dude
don't get out of my mind right now dude
trick or treat
oh god wait booby traps are illegal
well i mean this one hit an fbi agent
what's stafford doing on his property
because uh the real estate
a real estate attorney contacted the
authorities
because this man was asked to sell his
15 acre property
after they found that um there was this
elder abuse case involving his
90-year-old mother
and so he was jailed and then they told
him like he returned
and he had to sell his property
but you could force somebody to sell
your property yeah i don't get it but
then maybe there was like a
settlement or something or it could be
forfeit the house the mom's house and
they're like you need to get the [ __ ]
out of here
yeah so then when they went
there was a sign outside
that said beware of booby traps
um whom was it there was a sign
that said without the sign no smoking or
no
parking beware of dogs
beware of dogs it says the sign is
warning that the property
was protected by improvised devices
that's tight oh that's why i needed to
see the exactly so it's like a crossbow
improvised devices i would love my house
to have booby traps
what's an improvised device that's just
like a [ __ ] freestyle comedy crew
yeah you know what i want i want a house
that when an intruder comes in i just
want there to be [ __ ] metal bars to
come down
yeah and then loud ass [ __ ] blaring
because they'll freak them the [ __ ] out
yeah sorry i just pictured of my own
house that i want so i want my own house
to uh
be like a maze like a what is it that
mirror house oh yeah they can't figure
their way out no oh where bruce lee was
and uh
yeah but no mirrors just all clear glass
i could see them just [ __ ] smash
their faces
and some of them aren't even [ __ ]
clear glass it's just handles hanging on
a string
and they're just what is this
there's this dot there's this
documentary on youtube about like how
rich people
uh rigged their home with security and
all that and some of them
they they like rig guns and stuff in the
walls that they could control through
their phone
and if they're like yeah if someone like
breaks in or whatever
and then they showed like the [ __ ] that
it's crazy like they could press a
button
and it'll go boom and the whole wall
will start shooting at
you and [ __ ] yeah it's nuts so it's like
the the indiana jones but like with
bullets instead of those like darts
yeah yeah yeah like that so it's it's
all [ __ ] rigged and
i'm never gonna be that rich i just want
archaic [ __ ] though i like that but i do
like the crossbow idea because that
thing is gonna be in their chest
what's that thing called that you should
put the bottom yeah
oh it'll be dope if it literally the
[ __ ] roof open it just kind of pulls
them out your house boom
get them the jackass hand
yeah you just walk through the wrong
door and it's like
bam [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] i like seeing
people struggle so if it's like
if it's like a hole like or like a the
the steel doors if it caves in
and then it starts filling up with water
and then they only have like an inch
damn your masochistic dude
so like it's like how long you want to
survive is up to you
if you want to if you're going to drown
it in your job dude this guy rigged his
uh hallway because he kept getting
broken into
and then so he did he did it in a way
where like
once the robber got in both doors shut
and locked and he got stuck in there hi
yeah and you rigged cameras and
everything
that's dope yeah so well what this dude
did is he parked a minivan
across the driveway so vehicles can't
get in it's like really janky
kind of booby trap stuff um and then so
there were like
states and federal bomb technicians
and they found that that vehicle was
rigged with several
steel toothed traps that are used like
for wild
animals oh my [ __ ] bear traps owie
that's gonna break your [ __ ] leg off
and then near a second gate there was a
circular hot tub
that was sitting on its side and that
the tub was rigged so that if the gate
had been opened
a mechanical trigger would then make the
spa
roll toward the gate just look like that
that's like indiana jones
really readers on ball left this is so
[ __ ] kettle yeah
yeah were they laughing the whole time
we're looking at this [ __ ] no they were
they were like bomb technicians like
they were
i mean i'm assuming they're probably
like in that hurt locker suit right and
he's probably laughing inside the cage
that's funny i like when you can hear
your own laughter
yeah so then there was a wooden rat trap
near a garage door
and a trap was altered to have a
shotgun shell and then oh [ __ ] yeah
and then if the trap was somehow like
detonated then it would
open like by opening the door it would
shoot the shotgun that's how someone
one of the bomb technicians was hit oh
and then there was this also like this
wheelchair that had an explosive
charge on it dude this fool's watched
too much a team [ __ ]
yeah you got the throwback series and oh
man maybe i was watching home alone
because i remember like
i would always try to create traps and
you know when you're kid your
imagination is always too damn big
and in reality it's not that good like
like i would like
dig small little holes and then try to
like cover it with leaves and [ __ ]
and then it's like the leaves will keep
going in so then people just step into
it
and it's like [ __ ] that just gave them
cushion yeah
they made them those of their balance
maybe like whoa it's like
it didn't work or you think or you dig a
hole and then you cover it up with a
different colored leaf and this is
clearly there's a [ __ ] hole right
there yeah so this dude his name is
gregory
you fall on no holes oh look at those
patches i'm like
that's weird who cares and then boom all
the way down
yeah so this dude is gregory whoa
he looks like william defoe to me he
does i did not picture a guy like that
damn
it it's like he was cussing him out
mm-hmm
[Music]
[ __ ] he just looks like one of those
guys that tells you to get off the lawn
yeah like like when i when i picture
like a doomsday prepper that's like
super paranoid and
yeah they look way more like military
and [ __ ] you know
dude i [ __ ] love gran torino man
that's my [ __ ] movie dude
i'm not a big clint oh it's it's it's
good you might like it because is that
the one with the monks
yeah well i haven't seen it because i
grew up with a bunch of hmong people so
it was just like man they got this down
pat dude
this is like this is like straight up
how hmong people are man or like the
ghetto ones that i know of you know what
i mean
so it's cast actors of real people right
yeah
[ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy man and then the
acting was so bad
because they weren't actors yeah right
so there was this line that had me dying
he goes
oh what are you [ __ ] slan eyes eat
they're like
this is pretty good duh it's hmong food
i was like yikes what's acting is
terrible
that line is hilarious too but it's monk
food
i haven't seen it i thought the slanted
one was the funny part dude there were
so many racial terms i didn't know about
until
that film i feel like clint eastwood
made that film just so he can say
asian cuts like racist words like
[ __ ] i had no idea [ __ ] was
a was a derogatory term for asian people
but then since he made it he did it
right and it got the actual hmong people
and everyone so it was like okay
but that's like his inner way of talking
she's got the actual people
yeah it was actually i'm gonna do that
too i can't wait till i get all that
money
that's where you can do it cause like
during world war two they would run over
their faces
and they would just have tire tracks
that's what they would call zipper heads
that's why they're called zipper damn
people get so creative
yeah i was like holy [ __ ] i was like how
is that offensive i was like oh that is
really offensive
that's tragic wow yeah yeah so this dude
gregory he was charged with
assault on a federal officer and then
when they were questioning him if there
are more booby traps on the property
he's like
monty find out he said i would not race
right in
like oh damn what a thug dude he's like
i'm going die
that'd be so funny when they arrested
him he has like only two limbs because
he forgot where half his booby traps
were
it's like are you sure there's none he
goes i wouldn't erase what i did look at
this
oh maybe he wasn't even trying to
threaten him he really just forgot he
goes i don't know
i forgot why is he so like you're scared
i'm scared
worried like i wonder if he's like some
kind of like heroin dealer or like yeah
crackhead behavior yeah we'll be
trapping our house against
that is but he's he's doing some real
dope [ __ ] though like
like i think crackhead behavior is like
i don't know like
a really failed booby trap those are
pretty failed because they
it didn't work yeah one guy did get shot
though he did the last the very last one
kind of worked out but
he didn't die so true you didn't die i
feel like a crackhead booby trap
is like putting a bunch of toothpicks on
the ground and thinking that it's gonna
spike their feet when they step on it
that's a crackhead booby trap right
there do you ever play
any of these like like putting the push
pin upside down on your teacher's chair
absolutely what you'll find sick freak
why would you do that i wouldn't do that
but i see that [ __ ] on tv all the time
oh tv huh
yeah yeah tv yeah yeah the incredibles
had that scene too and then simpsons i
had a
whoopee cushion never had the balls for
that it never worked
i saw this one girl kick one of our
teachers in the stomach and she was
pregnant
oh [ __ ] yep that's not a booby trap
you come in so hard bad story yeah
that's sad
the baby lived i made a booby trap i was
playing war
with uh with our front neighbor and
i think we were probably like in second
or third grade but his older brother was
five years older than me
so on our side of the house i made all
these logs
and i tied them all with a string and
all it took was like if
at least when i tested it like if anyone
passed by and
hit the string all these logs would fall
on them that's pretty good
yeah but when the guy came he saw it he
just pushed it and then all the logs
fell on the
in front of him and i was like [ __ ]
didn't work at all and then we got our
ass beat
even harder for trying to because now he
was like oh so you
wanted to do that to me this is how logs
would feel and beat the [ __ ] out of us
[Music]
do